now have white working-class kids being
left behind in our education system
a report from a select committee in
parliament this week says that poor
white boys
perform worse than almost every other
group at every level of education
robert halfriend who chairs the
committee joins me now along with morris
macleod who's the chief exec
of race on the agenda an anti-racism
campaign group
now robert halford let's start with you
you took a question from nick gibb
during your inquiry
and he told you straight out that race
isn't a factor
it's poverty that holds people back so
have you guys been barking up the wrong
tree all along
well i massive respect for nick gibb i
approve what he's done to try and
improve standards
i think that his work on phonics and
literacy
is incredibly important but i have a
fundamental disagree with him and i
think his answer
was part of the muddled thinking that
has gone on for decades
in response to this problem we know that
there are
nine hundred thousand plus white working
class
uh pupils from disadvantaged backgrounds
on free school
uh meals we know that at every stage of
the education system
they underperform almost every other
ethnic group you know just
seventeen point seven percent get good
passes at gcse maths and english and
just sixteen percent
go to university and that's lower than
uh afro-caribbean
and other ethnic ethnic groups so
the stock answer to this has always been
uh
it's muddled and it's in some ways lazy
thinking
is that it is due to poverty and what is
needed is more of the same
policies from the department if it was
down to poverty
of course that's a factor why on earth
are other ethnic
communities for the most part performing
much better than disadvantaged white
working class
pupils and often the poverty levels of
those ethnic communities are even worse
than disadvantaged white communities
maurice mcleod your chief exec of race
on the agenda do you think it's right
that race
should be at the forefront of this
particular agenda when we're trying to
work out why
some kids do worse than others and we
should look at white working class as a
discreet group
yeah i think it's it's it's interesting
when i saw this report was coming out um
there have been a number it feels of
reports into
white working-class uh kids and they're
under achievement
um to my mind that the issue with
and it's it's right to highlight that
this this group the group that are on
free school meals which isn't the same
as saying
uh working class by the way sixty
percent of people consider themselves
working class but i think
uh sort of like fifteen or seventeen
percent of
kids are actually on free school meals
so that's it's not it doesn't map quite
as
as clearly as as maybe the headlines are
pretending
but they're to my mind they're not
disadvantaged because of their race
that's
that's why i i find the the framing
maybe of this this work slightly um
confusing
right and robert halfrim that's quite a
good point isn't it i mean you looked at
sam the phrase white privilege in your
report and you said you didn't think it
was a helpful
term but if you use language like this
that was quite
explosive several members of your
committee walked out um but you also
say that even the terminology isn't
quite there as maurice mcleod says
we're not really talking about white
working class new report you look at
kids on free school meals
now sure and they that's a subsection of
the working class but
there isn't even language here for what
you're
you're grasping not just for answers but
you're grasping for basic vocabulary
yeah the first point is we make it very
clear in the report the data set we're
looking at and we're looking
at a white working class boys and girls
on free school meals from disadvantaged
backgrounds and we explained that
in the in in the report of course there
is a generic term for white working
class but
that is the group that we are looking at
that underperform
as i say against almost every other
ethnic group now on the point of white
privilege
and the reason why we put this in report
the labour members didn't walk out they
just voted against the
report but the reason why we put it in
because it's wrong fundamentally wrong
for three reasons
so the first reason is that if you use
the concept of white privilege you are
implying
collective guilt when it should be
individual responsibility for acts of
racism
and the second reason is if you use the
word white privilege you're basically
telling
a poor a white community that they are
privileged you're telling
a single parent who might live in a tiny
flat in my constituency of harlow
doing their best to bring up their child
that they have white privilege
and the third reason is that it's
factually incorrect because all the data
shows
that far from being privileged in
education
these disadvantaged white communities
are doing worse
as a repeat than almost any other ethnic
group and i just
want to add that i am not this is you
know people go on about the culture wars
if you walk along the streets of my
constituency no one would even know what
the culture wars
are about i am uh raising this my
committee has raised this because what
all the people here and you can make an
intellectual argument about what right
with privilege means
but i'm a wrong sealed type politician
white privilege does what it says on the
tin it just tells people whatever their
background whatever their circumstances
that they have white privilege those are
the only two words
that they that they hear and it's wrong
it's being introduced by councils it's
being recommended by educational
uh groups it's got to stop uh spreading
it is not the way to deal with racism
maurice mccloud you must have some
sympathy with that i mean is white
privilege
a problematic does it does the very
phrase tell somebody in the council
state who's had no privilege at all in
their life but they're inherently well
off just because of the color of their
skin it's a form of racism isn't it
yeah so so i think the the white
privilege thing to me it's a bit of a
red herring i think that
that um you know getting obsessed on
whether that term
uh translates well with with a certain
audience isn't
isn't really the thing i i i don't think
so so
um yes you know arguing to someone
that's that's
really deprived that's that's that's saw
seeing all economy economics or benefit
go a different direction and telling
that person they've got privilege seems
like a a a hard thing to say but you
wouldn't find any difficulty telling
someone who's poor
and you know was really struggling yes
you're already poor but
aren't you better off than someone who
had who's disabled for instance that
they can they can understand that link
and i think that sometimes when we have
these sorts of conversations
um so if you're talking about for
instance the kids on free school
meals which is what we're talking about
white kids on free school meals and you
compare them to black kids on free
school meals and say look they're
they're they're achieving even worse
isn't that terrible this shows that
that it's because they're white and
they're being you know they're being
disadvantaged
surely the the the geography of where
people are
as as i think it says in the report
place matters now if you're comparing
you know kids in the north in a deprived
area with
uh black kids in london who yes uh have
equal levels of poverty or sometimes
even more poverty
but have other resources around them
because they happen to live in the south
where all of the
wealth has been extracted to you're not
comparing like would like
so so robert your your problem then is
that
you know you've got the debates but you
want to talk about the white working
class even that phrase is problematic
you talk about white privilege
it's so incendiary that you've got um
members of your committee who don't vote
with the report
and then if you read the report i have
to say i couldn't find very much in the
way of solutions from it
at the end and i think the um it seems
that there's a quote
i think from the from the new schools
network the center for social justice
saying that there were basically there
was no national solution to this problem
so aren't you really on a hiding to
nothing here you're you're sort of
going going into this sort of culture
warsy territory but to no real avail
well i think i think um
with respect massive respect to you
fraser that's wrong on all counts
because there were the report is full of
full of solutions to deal with this
problem i mean the pro the issue is
that um first of all in terms of even
discussing um the underperformance of
white working class boys and girls is
seen as a taboo issue and it isn't that
loads of people discussing whenever it's
raised you get a huge amount of
criticism we should be able to debate
things like
the terminology of white privilege
without being shouted down
um or without uh being described as i
have been by the neu as dr
shipman uh today or represented from the
neu we have to debate and discuss these
things
otherwise you just close down debate and
one side has all the
you're not tilting your windmills a
little bit here i mean however as you
say go into the streets people don't use
language like culture wars how often do
they come across
the language the problem is that it's
being the concept of white privilege as
being
recommended and introduced in our
education system recommended by
educational groups recommended by
uh councils and we've got examples of
that in the report but in terms of the
solutions again
that is wrong the report is full of
solutions changing the
what's happened often is that money has
been thrown at big cities so we had the
london challenge which has improved
london
schools but towns have been left behind
we recommend
to target much better the pupil
premium so that you target it down to
target funding down to at neighborhood
level where disadvantaged communities
live
we recommend that family hubs should be
put around in every town across the
country because early years intervention
makes a difference we've looked at the
what the felt and reach academy
do and suggest parental engagement
programs where parents have been
disengaged from
the curriculum and education from one
generation to the next
and it does work because we've seen
examples of it from felton reach we've
suggested
solutions in terms of increasing the
vocational elements of the curriculum
perhaps
having design and technology in the
bacchloria getting teachers to
disadvantaged areas by introducing
teaching degree apprenticeships and
bursaries and financial incentives and
training colleges or training providers
for those teachers
in disadvantaged areas we've suggested
adult community learning
centers in every town again to re-engage
parents we've looked at the university
access fund
800 million that's spent to try and get
disadvantaged pupils which
is not working at a university it's not
working at all and suggested that there
should be
targe proper targets from the office of
students to get more
white to disadvantaged students into
university but also
using it to fund more degree
apprenticeships so these pupils can earn
while they learn not worry about taking
on debt
get a skill and get a job at the end so
all the way through the report it is
lined
with explanation and aligned with with
solutions and the white
privilege argument is literally two or
three pages out of a
a 90-page report so the report is full
of solutions you may not agree with them
that is that is your right but it is
wrong to say that this is just a report
or imply that it's just a report about
the cultural uh whatever you call want
to call it the cultural battle cultural
wars
uh morris one of the things that does
come through from the reports
is the limitations even when you're
talking about bain for example that's a
generalization
but even black is a generalization
because the outcomes of black africans
are seem to be significantly worse and
then it's better sorry than for black
caribbeans and major parts the education
system
the same is true if you talk about south
asians the outcomes for indians tend to
be a lot better than whites
for pakistani and bangladeshi
backgrounds a lot worse
so isn't there a lot more nuance here
than ever labeled bame or even
south asian and black are these labels
starting to
to conceal more than they reveal um i'm
not sure that they're sick concealing
more than they reveal i do think there's
a problem
with labels it's one of the things that
is one of the things that the cred
report
pointed to which i think was it was kind
of a right to point out that the bain
sort of label lumps everyone in together
and there are so many different uh
experiences
that different groups have so i think i
think it's worth worth pointing out i do
i do think that i don't think that that
should be used to say okay so it's all
too complicated let's just not look at
it at all or
let's you know we do need to drill down
into individual communities we do need
to drill down and look at
the gypsy roma traveler communities and
work out why
they uh they are often um achieving so
much lower
than almost any other group these things
do matter and they do they are connected
to
to culture and to race and things like
that so what about white working class
though i mean do you accept there's a
problem there because if you look at
them
you'll see these league tables white
working class are the group least likely
to get
into university in this country more
than any other ethnic group
there are studies after studies which
show white white boys specifically white
working-class boys
as being the bottom of this pile so if
you care
about inequality i mean i've known you
for 20 years and you've always
been going on you've always been on the
side of those
and facing the the strongest headwinds
isn't there a case to say for whatever
reason
white working-class boys are facing
incredibly strong headwinds
in this country they may be in the
ethnic majority but they're really
facing problems
and if we care about those problems we
simply have to have these conversations
no matter how uncomfortable they might
be
absolutely no you absolutely have to
have the conversation but that what i'm
i guess challenging is that is is that
i don't think that this part of the
conversation needs to be racialized if
you're talking about working class
children and what they need and how they
need to be how their educational
uh standards needs to be lifted out and
how they've been sort of neglected for
for decades let's be honest
um nothing in the in the stuff that that
robert just said
uh um you know in the tools that are in
the
in the solutions that are in this report
none of them are specific to white
people i'm not really
sure why why label this as you know the
report into fixing
the they will they will both benefit
both they will benefit all disadvantaged
communities but they will also address
the problems
that disadvantaged white communities
face and
and also we're we're focusing a lot on
towns because if you look at the maps in
the report that is where
predominantly white working class
communities live and previously as i say
all the funds all the policy reform has
primarily be based
being based looking after the big cities
and the london challenge
which has improved london schools has
been a big example of that
a bit more to two points about poverty
though i mean if you look at for example
at chinese pupils and free school meals
their outcomes educationally are better
than than rich whites
so you can't say that or if if your
analysis was true then surely everybody
in free school meals would have the same
outcome
and in fact what this report shows is
the huge differentials and outcomes for
work for free school meal pupils
depending on their ethnicity
yeah i'm not at all arguing that i think
they're they're
when when we're talking about the white
working-class kids in particular
i think there's more i don't think i
still haven't heard any
explanation for why how their ethnicity
is part of the challenge for them i
think it's more to do with the geography
it's more to do with where
where they live in the country well
that's exactly what we said though if
you read the report that's exactly what
we've said and
and going back to the white privilege
argument it's other people who want to
turn into an ethnicity
by accusing people of being white
privileged who are not
um which is why we put those few pages
in the report about it to try
actually make this argument that it is
about place and it's about
a class and where people live and
there's regional equalities family
disengagement from
the curriculum multi-generational
disadvantage and
lack of attention paid to the fact that
these students don't go to
a university lack of attention paid to
the cultural
often the cultural factors which in
white communities they want more
vocational
education and apprentices can we talk a
bit more about that
which was quite interesting the cultural
aspects i mean
you have heard it argued that if you
take two kids and free school meals say
you've got a son of
take sergeant javid for example with son
of indian immigrants now they came to
this country mainly so their son could
avail himself
or the education system there his mom
took him from school to the library she
made him stay there until six o'clock
to learn and sasha javas and his brother
baz is now a commander
in the metropolitan police are great
examples of the british dream
but it said look that is in any way a
quite
quite well understood immigrants story
but compare that to white working class
culture where you've got parents
who will have had a very different
experience perhaps of the education
system
it was not obvious to them that working
hard at school particularly paid
dividends in life so they're not going
to prioritize it
as parents and so perhaps that culture
could be something and it's very
difficult that's exactly like what
sounds as if you're talking down
but no we actually got uh we've actually
looked at this
in the in the report you're exactly
right and we make the point as funny
enough the
the commission for race disparity also
made the point that often new immigrant
families coming in
that they see education as a root out of
poverty and my father was an immigrant
to this country he worked there night i
actually got sent to a private school
my father came here with nothing but
work day night because his
view was education was everything and
that would be
a you know mean we would have success
success in life what has happened with
many disadvantaged white communities
is for one reason and another they were
let down in previous generations often
by the education system
or became disengaged from it they became
just and they passed that on from one
generation to the next that
that disengagement and that's why we've
talked about family hubs and parental
engagement programs and looked at the
remarkable work of fels mooch academy
and others
and seen see whether or not it can be
replicated to re-engage those families
into the education system so we don't
kind of perpetuate this for
you know this kind of disengagement for
infinity and uh
you know so this is why this report is
about a lot more than just two
the two words of what of white white
privilege although nevertheless it is an
important subject as i say to be debated
on mars cloud that's an interesting
point isn't it
i mean clean color aside you do have an
issue here
of white working-class parents who would
have been hit by perhaps the
industrialization in the 80s
who would whose grandparents might have
come from a culture as my dad was when
you basically left school at 15 that's
what you did
nobody expected it to be any different
so it's not so much skin color it's more
culture it's what your parents
experience is what they expect it's what
your grandparents expected
and that is simply different for the
children of
white working class than it is i don't
know perhaps for the
for the young children of immigrants
like sasha javi's parents who would have
come here thinking to themselves
this this school is going to be the
ladder from my son all the way up what
white
working class might not have the same
perspective or historical experience
yeah i i'm sure that um uh
intergenerational memory and all that
sort of stuff comes into it
you know none of this all this stuff is
nuanced so so i don't think you can just
look at
um uh um just say okay these ingredients
came in and they did well
therefore therefore there's not a
problem with the system now it might be
that there
you don't you're not comparing light for
light necessarily if you i know a lot of
um
my friends whose families came from
africa were asian but families came from
africa
uh during the sort of 80s and 70s they
didn't come in
poor they didn't come to this country in
the same way that that maybe
my mum when she came over from jamaica
came over she wasn't dirt poor but she
didn't come over
with with with any amount of wealth she
came over to
to sort of start at the bottom and work
so there's a different yeah
yeah comparing those two outlooks and
those two
uh ways of bringing up children
obviously uh comes into it but you can't
i don't think you can ignore
the the racialized nature of of
existence
especially for people from minority
ethnic communities in britain that that
is something that follows through and if
you're looking if you're saying uh
um parents aren't instilling the value
of education in their kids
kids aren't stupid they look and they
see their big brothers and people from a
few years older than them
who've gone through education who've
done you know done all the right things
and aren't and still aren't getting on
so you need to
to take into account you know what
what's the actual offer with education
what what are you what are you being
promised
[Music]
you